all right at 6 23 here on a tuesday
morning and it is
night three of hanukkah yes we've been
talking about this all week we're so
glad to have you here joining us now to
talk more about the jewish holiday and
all of the traditions and and some of
the fun things that all the food uh
rabbi levi harling and it's actually
pronounced
so so he
he can go by levi but of course
from shabbat of southern nevada and of
course we saw the dancing dreidels a
minute ago we'll get back to them but
the most important thing is is for you
to celebrate this holiday and for
everybody to understand how it works and
what it is so so talk to us about the
story of hanukkah thank you for having
me first of all so happy hanukkah
tonight is night number three the story
of hanukkah takes place a little over
two thousand years ago
the jewish people were under greek
syrian rule and they came up they tried
to influence us change our religion
abandon our faith they came up with some
harsh decrees forbidding us from keeping
our religion
two two quick miracles of the story is
number one the jews formed a small army
called the maccabees they were small in
number
they were overpowered by the greek
syrians but they were victorious in
battle a miracle from god they come back
to the temple miracle number two they
wanted to light the menorah manoa had to
be lit with pure olive oil that had to
seal the high priest it was contaminated
they found one small drug which is only
enough to light for one day but they
have faith in god they lit the menorah
and it lasted for eight days so we
celebrate hanukkah for eight days and
eight nights and eight days and that's
why some of the hanukkah traditional
food their food is fried in oil because
of the
miracle of the oil yeah miracles
let's get into it for the traditions
well again we'll have we have the
dreidels here uh obviously the menorah
is here uh potato pancakes latkes
[Laughter]
deep fried and all the miracle of the
oil we have the chocolate coins hanukkah
is about chinook education
educate the children giving charity
giving gifts and then we have the
dreidels we got the world famous dancing
dreads these are little plastic toys
yeah
four people letters on it during the
story the jews were forbidden to study
so they used to hide in the caves and
play with rails instead as a cover-up oh
that makes perfect sense okay wonderful
so so the children but also for the
adults as well it's something to
celebrate obviously but have a little
fun correct family time competitive but
it's really competitive i like that and
it's such a a big jewish community in
las vegas so many events around the
valley as well uh talk about some of the
things that people can take part in uh
right now sure so we have multiple
events every single day of hanukkah
throughout the city tonight's at the
district of henderson of the district
we've got saturday night in front of the
venetian sunday we got at a legion
stadium by the raiders game
hanukkah celebration
and toshiba plaza before the nights came
as well bringing the message of hanukkah
out to the public i think that's so
important for all of us to understand
and you guys get to have a little bit of
fun too because the message is the story
but then that resonates with people when
they see the incredible dancing dreidels
yes should we get into it they're world
famous and they came here to bring the
energy of the vacation oh wonderful
rabbi so let's take it away
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just kidding i've ever danced
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you